what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we finally got
Daredevil in She-Hulk it took Eight
Episodes but it finally happened and
even though the finale is next week we
only have one episode left we still
don't really know who the main villain
is of this show yes we know that it is
intelligencia but who is behind
intelligencia what do they want and who
is the real villain behind the show
there are many different theories out
there right now that it could be taught
it could be Titania it could be red Hulk
it could be Modoc there's a lot of
people it could be so today we're going
to talk about the finale and who the
villain might be and how it might set up
other future Marvel movies that are
coming up pretty soon and of course
we'll break down the episode and talk
about some pretty cool Easter eggs they
included in episode 8. if you're a fan
of Marvel be sure to subscribe to the
channel and hit that notification Bell
as we talk about Marvel almost every day
now this episode is titled Ribbit and
rip it which is the catchphrase of
LeapFrog and it's kind of a pun off of
grip it and rip it and I kind of like
how they portray trade LeapFrog in this
episode in the comics he's not really a
major character but he is kind of the
butt of the joke in the comics a lot and
I'm expecting it to kind of be the same
in the MCU I don't really think we'll
see him pop up much more now in this
episode they kind of combined two
characters into one in the comics
LeapFrog is actually Vincent patilio who
is Eugene's father in She-Hulk we meet
Eugene patilio who was LeapFrog but in
the comics he is actually frog man
Vincent patilio was a failed inventor
and due to him not making any money he
resorted to criminal activities to
provide for his wife and his son Eugene
he ends up creating these coils that
allow him to jump really really high so
he ends up donning the Frog costume
calling himself leapman and he ends up
trying to rob a bunch of different
places however he runs into Daredevil a
few times until Daredevil eventually
manages to arrest him they go to court
in which LeapFrog tries to escape but he
jumps up the courtroom window and he
ends up breaking his legs which is kind
of what we see happen in the warehouse
when he tries to run away he jumps out
the window his suit else he breaks both
his legs now it's worth noting that
Eugene in the comics is actually good
Frogman is a good character but his
father Vincent LeapFrog is bad so they
switched it here on us in fact when
She-Hulk is talking to her boss he says
that Eugene's father Vincent is one of
their biggest clients and that he is
very very rich so that's very different
than the comics and of course instead of
Eugene being frog man he is LeapFrog and
he is bad but just like in the comics he
is still kind of the butt of the joke
and the fight that we see in the
beginning when he uses his rocket
boosters he ends up catching himself on
fire so he wants to sue Luke who
designed his outfit but jyn doesn't want
to represent him because Luke also
designs all of her clothes and she's had
a really hard time finding clothes that
fit her and this is where we hear the
part where her boss says you have to
represent him his father Vincent is one
of their biggest clients so we go to
court and of course who is representing
Luke Matt Murdock Daredevil himself now
it was amazing to see Matt Murdock back
in action the way he talked about the
law and the way that he argued in the
court was simply fan fantastic I love
seeing it again he was very calm he was
very cool collected he was also very
charming and we actually learned
something extremely important during the
scene that the sokovia Accords have been
repealed if you don't remember the
sokovia chords they were introduced in
Captain America Civil War the sokovia
Accords were a legal act that was
designed to regulate the activities of
enhanced individuals including members
of the government like shield and of
course private organizations like The
Avengers they were basically designed to
keep enhanced individuals in check to
keep superheroes in check so they can't
just do what they please but they have
to report to the United Nations now in
the comics this does lead to superheroes
identities being disclosed and them
being attacked because people know who
they actually are in this scene Matt
Murdoch states that the scovia Accords
have been repealed and superheroes need
their identities to be concealed they
need them to be private so this was a
huge important scene and I'm sure this
will come into play in Captain America
New World Order which we're about to get
into in a bit now of course we find out
that Eugene LeapFrog is still kind of
the butt of the joke in the MCU as he
States in court that he used jet fuel
instead of regular fuel of course Luke
says that was against his instructions
so of course the case kind of gets
thrown out right away Matt Murdoch and
Luke win after this jyn ends up meeting
Matt Murdock again in a bar they end up
talking to each other and Jen actually
says that Eugene was actually dumber
than she thought he was she asked Matt
Murdock how he knew about the jet fuel
of course he smelled it due to his
enhanced senses and of course as is
mentioned in Spider-Man no way home he's
a really good lawyer now here's a really
cool scene where Matt Murdock is
actually kind of mentoring gin of course
he knows that jyn is She-Hulk but at
this point in time she does not know
that Matt Murdock is Daredevil in fact
she doesn't even know who Daredevil is
because when she meets him he has to
actually tell her I'm Daredevil now in
this scene we get a really cool mention
of Hell's Kitchen back in New York where
Matt Murdock is from where he does all
the dirty work as Matt Murdock as a
lawyer and of course as Daredevil as a
superhero it's worth noting that in this
series obviously we get Daredevils red
and yellow suit which is taken right
from the comics his suit is originally
red and yellow because it's designed
after his father's boxing robe his
father was a boxer who ends up getting
killed because he refused to throw a
match this is actually what sparks Matt
Murdoch to be a lawyer and of course a
superhero as well and this actually ties
into what he tells Jin at the bar saying
that she's in a unique position to
actually do some real good because Jen
Walters can use the law to help people
when Society fails them and She-Hulk can
help people when the law fails them and
this is obviously what he does as well
being a lawyer and of course being a
superhero now they both end up getting
called away Matt being called away
because Luke has been kidnapped by
Eugene AKA LeapFrog and Jin gets called
Away by Todd who we all just love so
much at the meeting Todd explains that
he bought an authentic wakandan War
spear however apparently wakanda wants
it back because it was stolen by
colonizers which could be a reference
and callback to claw now what's really
interesting about this scene is that it
doesn't really go anywhere of course
he's a slime ball and she refuses to
kind of help him so it makes you
question the importance of the scene but
the importance of this scene is the fact
that Todd now has something made of
vibranium and I do believe that Todd is
at least one of the villains if not the
main villain of She-Hulk and I think he
used this wakandan spear because it's
made out of vibranium to create that big
vibranium needle that we saw at the end
of episode six I do believe Todd is Hulk
King but I don't believe he is the
person who is in charge of intelligencia
I think he's working for them and he's
in charge of a specific task but I do
believe that there's somebody above him
and we'll get to that in just a bit now
eventually jyn gets a call from Eugene
who says he is being attacked and of
course he's being attacked by Daredevil
because Eugene actually kidnapped Luke
however jyn uses this opportunity to
kind of reflect on the words that Matt
told her in the bar that She-Hulk can
actually save people when the law fails
them so she grabs her new She-Hulk
outfit which of course Luke designed for
her and she goes and she meets Eugene
and Daredevil from here we get a really
awesome fight between Daredevil and
She-Hulk and we see a lot of really cool
things from the comics Daredevil is back
in action and his moves are better than
ever he's is very smooth and his moves
are pretty seamless ultimately She-Hulk
would end up hitting Daredevil with a
Thunderclap which of course probably
hurt more than it would a normal person
because considering how it hurt Hulk's
ears in episode 1 and Matt Murdock has
enhanced senses it probably hurt him a
little bit more it also launches him in
the air which causes She-Hulk to be able
to grab him and she instantly takes off
his mask and discovers that it's Matt
Murdoch she instantly asks if he's
pretending to be blind and he says no I
have a spatial method that I used to see
she says it's like echolocation and he
says kind of I basically have really
good hearing or at least I did and this
is a reference to that Thunderclap that
I was speaking of how it hurt him more
than it would a normal person because of
his enhanced hearing but of course he's
joking about it so he's not really
injured jyn asks him are you like a
superhero and which immediately Matt
Murdoch gets a weird expression on his
face and she asks are you the gold devil
in which again he is even more confused
and he says I'm Daredevil wondering how
she hasn't heard of him from here
Daredevil and jyn go to save Luke from
Eugene and we get more of an Insight on
Daredevil's Powers he says there are 25
five goons in the building he knows this
because he can hear their heart beats
Daredevil wants to sneak in and take out
each of them one by one but jyn says I'm
a Hulk why don't I just go in and smash
ultimately it's a combination of both of
these that they do to eventually get to
Eugene and it's awesome because we get
one of the infamous Daredevil hallway
fight scenes it's as if we are watching
a Netflix episode of Daredevil it's
fantastic and I loved every second of it
now here we get a look at Jin's She-Hulk
costume that Luke designed for her and
this has taken pretty much exactly from
the comics we get the purple and white
look but it also looks like it's been
upgraded a little bit and kind of looks
like the Avengers Quantum realm Suits
now jyn She-Hulk smashes as she says and
this causes Eugene and his goons to hear
them this is where we get a look inside
of the lair and we can actually see that
LeapFrog has a leapfrog signal of course
this is taken from Batman as Batman has
the back signal and we noticed some
other things like an arcade machine of
the old game Frogger which is obviously
very fitting for Leapfrog now of course
Daredevil and She-Hulk end up cleaning
up they rescue Luke the cops come and we
see see Daredevil and She-Hulk talking
and then of course she takes him home
and She-Hulk ends up smashing again
Daredevil does an hilarious Walk of
Shame afterwards and then we actually
get yet another Wolverine Easter egg in
She-Hulk Jen breaks the fourth wall and
says that this would be the perfect time
to end the episode however Nikki shows
up and reminds her of the gala Nikki
pops out from around the corner with
makeup brushes in her hand but she jumps
out and she uses them like their
Wolverine claws notice that she has only
three in each hand this is very very
specific and is not the first Wolverine
Easter egg that we got remember in the
first episode we got an Easter egg that
said in an online article that said man
fights with metal claws and bar brawl
basically confirming that Wolverine
already exists in the MCU and now we get
this as well we also have the
announcement that Hugh Jackman is
returning as Wolverine but of course we
know that he's not going to be the main
MC Wolverine he's probably only going to
be in Deadpool 3 and then hopefully
Secret Wars but will not be the main
Wolverine moving forward but she holds
kind of hints that we could be getting
that main Wolverine introduced
relatively soon as it's clear here that
he does exist in the MCU now of course
jyn goes to the gala where we can see
that her parents are there to support
her and then we also see that Todd is
conveniently there as well and of course
as Jen and other female lawyers are
accepting their Awards Intelligentsia
interrupts they hate She-Hulk and they
talk about how she should not be awarded
they call her a [ __ ] and this obviously
pisses jyn off as it would anybody else
and Jen ends up going full Hulk and
smashing the TVs and gets very very
angry and this could possibly be the
first time that we've seen her not
really in control of her anger or her
Hulk form now she sees some people that
are clearly behind what is happening
part of intelligencia they're wearing
face masks and she goes and she manages
to grab one and I do believe that this
is Todd the hair does look kind of
similar Todd was also wearing glasses
inside of the gala and this person is
wearing glasses as well now the dodc
shows up and we can see that they kind
of have the same guns that they were
using in Miss Marvel it is quite
convenient how they showed up relatively
fast almost like they knew what was
going to happen this is very suspicious
but it's most likely that somebody from
Intelligentsia tipped them off now as I
mentioned I do believe that the villain
is going to be Todd but I don't think he
is the only villain and I definitely
don't think that he is in charge of
Intelligentsia but what I do believe is
happening is that we're going to have
multiple people going up against
She-Hulk I do think that Todd in some
way shape or form is going to inject
himself with she-hulk's blood and
possibly become a Hulk I do also believe
that the leader is behind intelligencia
we know that Captain America 4 is going
to feature more than one Hulk and with
the leader confirmed to be the villain
of Captain America 4 this makes sense it
also makes sense that this episode and
the finale would lead us into Captain
America 4 as it does have the Hulk
connection and the She-Hulk blood now we
also do have Modoc coming in Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and the comics
Modoc is a key member of Intelligentsia
along with the leader but there also are
a couple of more people who could be
villains keep in mind Titania is still
out there somewhere really hating on XI
Hulk right now we know that she is very
rich so she does have the means of
possibly teaming up with Intelligentsia
possibly funding them because she might
want she-hulk's blood for herself so she
can become even stronger and so she
could defeat She-Hulk finally also
Mallory in the comics does end up
helping a company that tries to create
their own She-Hulk as well we did see
her actually with Todd at the law firm
in another episode this could actually
hint that the two of them are indeed
working together now overall I do think
that the big reveal is going to be that
Todd is actually behind everything again
in episode 6 we saw people in a lab who
now had a vibranium needle again I think
this is most likely made from the
vibranian wakandan warspear that Todd
obtained that they somehow managed to
make that into a needle this is why Todd
can't simply give back the spear and why
he needs a lawyer it is also even more
suspicious that he asked to meet with
Jennifer Walters slash She-Hulk when he
before it was already meeting with
Mallory so most likely Todd is the big
twist that Jennifer Walters has teased
in this episode she also didn't mention
a red Hulk and there is of course the
possibility that Thunderbolt Ross could
show up as a red Hulk there's a big
rumor going around that Harrison Ford
has been cast as Thunderbolt Ross to
essentially recast the character since
sadly William Hurt passed away but since
the leader is going to be the main
villain of Captain America 4. it makes
sense that Thunderbolt Ross would show
up again as well especially with the
Thunderbolts coming so all in all I do
think Todd is the big twist but of
course he is going to be working for
somebody else as well this person is
most likely going to be the leader or
perhaps Thunderbolt Ross but let me know
what you think in the comments down
below did you enjoy this Daredevil
episode and who do you think is the real
villain of She-Hulk let me know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe stay up to date
on all the latest MCU news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
or Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf
me